next question for eric from gonz and oak
how long uh how long does it take
metabolically
to recover from long duration diets
so for example a show prep that you have
to push for a great number of months
so i feel like every question we get we
start with like a
list of caveats but this isn't just
for bodybuilding competitors
you know people go on diets for a
variety of reasons and
the the goals of those diets are
certainly quite different but
um i i think because there's a lot of
content out there about recovering from
really intense prep diets
that people have i'm not saying that the
person asking this question is but
i see a lot of people who are like okay
so i dieted for six months how do i
recover from this but what you find is
it was six months of a very
very chill diet wasn't a super fast rate
of weight loss they didn't get super
lean and they did not lose that much
weight
doesn't mean their diet didn't work it
means they took a very conservative
approach and they got to a healthy body
weight
that is good so but but what i'm getting
at
is recovery from a diet depends on
how long was it how it how extreme was
the rate of weight loss
and essentially how lean did you get at
the end
and also what was the the total
magnitude of weight loss
so even if you didn't get exceptionally
lean you might be in an interesting
physiological state if you just lost
100 pounds um
[Music]
at the same time you know you might be
in a super interesting state if you
didn't necessarily lose
that much weight but you went from
sustainably lean to unsustainably lean
for a photo shoot or competition or
whatever for your wedding
you know people diet for all sorts of
reasons um
so the the general premise there is that
it the recovery duration
uh because the question is how long does
it take the recovery duration depends on
how extreme the diet was
and we also have to consider what the
word recovery entails
so a lot of people wonder if my
metabolic rate or my energy expenditure
energy expenditure seems low
if my energy expenditure seems low how
long will it take for that to go back to
normal
sometimes people say hey my testosterone
is low when is that going to recover
i'm not performing well in the gym when
is that going to recover i have no
libido
or i've been missing my periods or i
can't sleep at night or i'm extremely
hungry
there are many different facets of
recovery
that all seem to recover on slightly
different time scales
and one of the critical things
determining that time scale is how much
you actually commit
to recovering so i'm gonna
for this question i'm gonna assume that
you
you dieted to an extreme enough level
that recovery is needed which again
is not everybody if you're at a
sustainable body weight and you took a
conservative approach to dieting you
probably don't need to recover at all
really but let's say you do need to
recover you know you're
you're in this state where energy
expenditure is low your hormones are a
mess your performance sucks you have no
libido all that stuff
the rate of your recovery is going to be
predicated largely on how much you over
feed
and to some degree the the regain of
weight is probably going to drive some
of this recovery
how much weight do you need to regain it
really depends on what a good
sustainable
non-dieting body fat is for you you know
not everyone has the same
minimum body fat level they can that
they can comfortably maintain
but you got to kind of play with it and
figure out what that is but
i can tell you that if your body's
typically nice and comfortable and
things are great at
13 body fat as a male and you're trying
to hang around at six percent for a
while
your recovery could essentially just not
happen i mean
you you can basically just keep yourself
in that state if you don't commit to
actually
increasing your energy intake putting a
little bit of weight back on
and really prioritizing that recovery so
what we can do is we can look at studies
that have looked at this recovery in
people that have done bodybuilding or
physique related preps
and there there's a few case studies
there is a really nice study by you ha
homie
and his colleagues over in finland where
they actually had a decent sized sample
of females that that did a prep and a
recovery
when we look at the at this data
or this body of research as a whole
the hormones that are associated with
short-term energy availability so
looking at things like ghrelin and
thyroid hormone insulin cortisol
those seem to recover pretty
substantially within the first three to
four months
some hormones take a little bit longer
testosterone levels in males
don't get they start certainly start
recovering within that three to four
month time range but they might not be
back to near
totally normal baseline levels until
like five or six months for a lot of
people
um same thing with leptin obviously
leptin is closely tied to
how full your fat cells are so certainly
if you try to stay super lean the
leptin's just not coming back
for most people if if you diet and then
recover but you're this is something
i've always wondered about leptin so it
does seem
to kind of maybe govern set points to
some degree
and it's based partially on what you're
eating
partially on energy availability and
partially on
the fullness of of said fat cells so i
was wondering
like if let's say someone starts at
25 body fat they cut to 5
um because you know they very
aggressively wanted to do a bodybuilding
show and
started from a very very deep off season
and then they want to like settle at 15
after the recovery do those leptin
levels get back to normal because
those fat cell so like 15 is generally a
pretty
normal healthy body comp but those fat
cells are going to be a lot
less full at 15 than 25 so like
does leptin like
does recovery of leptin happen if people
don't
get all the way back up to the body comp
or i guess
down back down to the body comp they
started with
without having data in front of me i
certainly wouldn't expect it to
to get all the way straight back to
baseline i would expect it to be at a
new baseline
because again those those fat cells are
in a very different state
but i would think that it should at
least be within a what we would consider
like a normal reference range
gotcha whereas when they're when they're
down in prep level it will probably be
comfortably below the normal reference
range
so i don't think the goal should be to
get leptin necessarily back
to its baseline value because as you get
very
obese you can drive those leptin levels
through the roof
and it i mean if you want to get those
levels when you're down at like 13
body fat good luck but i i would say
that it's probably an advisable goal to
try to get back
within the reference range and what you
might find is that
even though even though the leptin level
doesn't quite settle back at its highest
number especially if you start with a
decent amount of body fat
you might find that you know leptin's a
little bit lower but the things we
associate with leptin
are still regulated very normally just
because leptin sensitivity improves
exactly yeah i would expect that if you
started with
super inflated leptin levels you
probably had some degree of leptin
resistance
uh in many cases that makes sense so
yeah
that's a really good point of something
to keep in mind is that
the goal doesn't necessarily need to be
to get every aspect of your
to re retain every aspect of what you
did
when you were at a substantially higher
body fat but now at a lower one
so like for instance let's say you
started out
25 body fat like your example but strong
as
hell right and you you dyed it down to
five percent or whatever
and you settle back at 13 in the off
season you at 13
is still going to be a much smaller
person than you used to be at 25
you're not going to recover all your
strength you know so
in in most cases um and so that that's
something to keep in mind is that
if you're not interested in getting all
the way back to your starting weight
you're going to have to make some
concessions in terms of how you view
recovery
but generally speaking i would say as
long as you're
allowing a somewhat generous rate of
weight regain to put you back at a still
decently lean but at least sustainable
body fat
usually within six months you should for
most outcomes be about
where you're going to be you know it
should be you shouldn't be thinking like
well over the next 18 months i'm going
to start feeling normal
if that's the case you need to make some
more concessions and start eating more
you you should really try you should aim
to be feeling yourself again
within a few months and then essentially
fully recovered within
six i think um one thing that is
extremely unpredictable though i don't
want to spend a ton of time on it but
i've said it before the recovery of a
normal menstrual cycle
is so difficult uh when you look at the
research the amount of variability is
really wild so
there was a case study the first
author's last name was holiday
and in that case study the participant
it took a full
71 weeks to to get back to
uh i don't know if it was the first
menstrual cycle or when
it was a fully normal menstrual cycle um
but i remembered like it took a full 71
weeks to get the menstrual cycle at
least
operating again and that was with
a competitor that did regain close to if
not all of their body weight i actually
think they regained a little bit more
than they lost during the prep
there there are also some some larger
studies in non-physique athletes looking
at like dancers and
various endurance athletes with like
menstrual disorders
and even when they do like nine 12
months
12-month interventions it's really hit
or miss about who's going to recover and
who isn't
and there's even a study by chew
at all c-h-o-u in 2011.
they kind of took a really extreme
approach with exogenous leptin
injections
and uh menstruation uh it was restored
in only seven of the ten subjects
undergoing the injections and it was
restored in a span of three to
or i'm sorry four to 32 weeks in those
seven that did have restoration
so was that just leptin injections or
leptin injections
along with overfeeding and some other
sort of intervention
i would imagine i'm not certain but i'd
be shocked if they didn't have at least
some other kind of intervention to make
sure that their
diet and exercise habits were conducive
to you know
like getting them at least back to a
somewhat appropriate
energy availability level i'd be stunned
if that wasn't part of the intervention
um i'd have to go back and check but
that would be a pretty nonsensical
intervention if they if they gave them
left
leptin
injections and then just said yeah but
you can still have totally disordered
eating and run
eight hours a day so i would imagine
that there was at least some degree of
of restriction over those aspects but um
in any case to put in a nutshell um
i was having a discussion with uh
brandon roberts peter fitchen and eric
helms
and all you know we were going back and
forth about like how long does it take
to recover
and we're like i don't know man where
did you start how lean did you get
how much are you over feeding um
are you willing to regain your weight
how much of it should you regain
um we're trying to put together like a
decent estimate on the time
and i think essentially we reach the
conclusion that it's like
time is not a good way to to approximate
that it it really comes down to a
multi-factorial approach
after the competition or after this
dieting phase you need to manage your
training volume
you need to manage your energy
availability and you need to get back to
a sustainable body fat
if all of those are met all of those
conditions are met in a timely manner
within the first
you know three four five weeks after
competition you're at least
moving in those directions i would
expect that
you know with a with a steady rate of
weight regain and immediately getting to
a
a decent training volume and a decent
energy availability status i would say
somewhere within three to six months you
should be feeling pretty alright